[Music]
all right new york city mayor bill de
blasio celebrating the essential workers
of the pandemic in a hometown heroes
ticker tape parade yesterday but some of
the city's first responders say
the event which was scaled back because
of the heat was not what they were
hoping for here to explain 13-year
veteran new york city's emergency
medical
services uh para uh paramedic liana
espinal
uh lyanna what is your complaint about
yesterday's
very hot celebration uh good morning
so my complaint about yesterday's
celebration is
it's a clear it's a clear sign that we
needed to be celebrated that we put in a
lot of work
the first responders and all the
essential workers
but giving us a parade just shines light
on how much
we need to raise we need more money the
thank you and the praise and the parade
it's nice
and but it just doesn't put food on the
table and it doesn't allow us to take
care of our families
right and they didn't give you a day off
to attend right
no definitely not so you lose a day's
pay to go to a parade that's in honor of
you
so in in turn what was it been like for
the last year for you in particular
working through kobit was very difficult
for many reasons it was difficult
because we saw more death than we'd ever
seen before it was difficult because
some of us were separated from our
families
it was difficult for a lot of people
because
they couldn't separate from their
families they risk putting their
families in dangers
in danger they lost family members you
know it was it was very
mentally and emotionally and physically
stressful for
us as a whole not just for myself
and if you want to see appreciation uh
show us in the pay
now with uh now with a parade show us in
the pay not with the parade allow us to
be able to take care of our families
without having to
work 80 hours a week you know you can't
take care of your family
and not be there for them because you
have to be at work so much
yeah absolutely cop i know cop says the
same thing i got to go home but i got to
stay away from my family because i have
no idea what i was exposed to to a
mysterious virus
we still don't know where it came from
the mayor's office was asked to respond
to the criticism they say new york
gathering
celebration for essential workers
through the darkest times it was the
kickoff the summer new york city
deserves
it was the least we could do for our
hometown heroes uh this parade was about
them but they didn't give you a day off
and they haven't increased your pay we
appreciate you
i i hope you you feel a little of that
because you certainly deserve it leona
espinel thank you so much
thank you so much